right so if you've ever thought about
quitting your job to follow your passion
or start a business or anything like
that then you're going to want to watch
this clip from my conversation with
james hoffman if you don't know james
he's one of the world's most famous and
respected people in the world of coffee
and he's managed to turn his passion and
hobby for coffee into a thriving
business with an enormous following on
youtube along with a coffee roasting
business along with a coffee shop along
with like a best-selling book and we
talk a little bit into how money falls
into the equation of quitting your job
compared to things like meaning and
altruism and learning and purpose and
all that other kind of stuff i hope you
enjoy the clip how important do you
think it is if let's say someone wants
to quit their job and start a business
today for them to have a wider
altruistic somewhat vision behind it
that's other than
i need a business to make money because
i want to try and quit my job and do
something that's fun if they wish to
derive satisfaction from the work they
do i think it's essential
because earning from i mean for a
certain sort of mind just just
extracting wealth is satisfying they see
the number get bigger and that's
satisfying enough but for most people
it's quite hollow and empty and
unsatisfying and they end up doing work
they don't like because the number goes
up but they don't feel good about it and
they look for something else so i think
having a purpose or a meaning behind it
for me is essential like what am i you
know i mean i i i don't really believe
in legacy
but i i think it's a shame not to to
leave something better than you found it
that seems you know what i mean like
this the decent thing to do so i i want
to improve things or be have a positive
impact and so that's driving a lot of
the decisions i might make around
starting businesses or doing stuff like
that and i would say the people who
enjoy their work the most
i've met miserable billionaires you know
what i mean like miserable people
because they're just what the number's
very big
so what now slightly bigger like what is
that that is you know they're just
miserable uh i have no aspiration
for that um
so yeah for me i think it's essential if
you want to enjoy the work you do and
feel like it has meaning and purpose
yeah there has to be vision nice and is
this how you were feeling in the early
days as well or is this something a
philosophy that's developed over time
that's a good question i i think um
like uh
i'm i'm aware that i grew up middle
class and so i grew up with a safety net
in that i started a business and i was
never going to go to to zero you know
what i mean and i think that that's
always worth noting in people like me
who took risks started businesses there
was a safety net
i was gonna be okay and i you know i
mean that changes your relationship with
money i think if you don't have a safety
net
then i i'm much more open to the idea of
like no i need money i need to build my
safety net because i don't have one um
but but i was aware i did and so for me
you know i was a very passionate person
about the product i just really i really
enjoy coffee i get very excited about it
and so that was always a driver for me
but i also like learning stuff and so
you know learning to build a business
with satisfying learning to sell or
market or do the other things that went
alongside that so with youtube now like
learning to shoot better films uh
do better audio light properly all of
those things i enjoy that process that's
just part of
me i like the the constant obsession
it's just it's just very satisfying to
get better at something i like that i'm
always going to like that this is what
it is
so yeah i i think i wasn't super money
focused i didn't earn very much from the
business for a long time
and and
um
you know
even now i i think my my
because we've always been bootstrapped
so the coffee company's bootstrapped
everything else has really been
bootstrapped uh i have um
left it in a lot of the time like i i
like uh especially going to pandemics or
going into whatever the economy is going
to do now
having
cash inside a business is a good thing
to me
and that's just because i don't like to
be responsible to other people because i
suppose i have a bit of a control freak
aspect to me uh and it's not like i'm
against investment or i'm against
you know
raising money in different ways but i
just like the control it's just how
we've always done it like we've done
everything out of cash from the
beginning and you would argue and i
would hear you and say you're probably
right that was not the best use of that
money
that we could have
you know
borrowed leveraged the business a little
bit borrowed a ton of cash grown faster
done all those things
but if the goal is the goal is to make
better stuff and feel good about it then
that was not a route we needed to go so
so yeah like uh historically you know we
can talk about money i guess a bit i've
never already pulled tons out of the
business which is
maybe foolish you know what i mean i
never really cashed the chips in so to
speak but i you know i'm interested in
the businesses that that i work with
doing the work and being
long-term sustainable so so yeah that's
been the general approach interesting
yeah there's a a a good book by uh matt
mccree the the great ceo within um one
of the things he says is that because he
he does a lot of coaching for like uh
tech founders silicon valley types
um and he says that basically people
want to go people want to work or start
business for three reasons to make money
to have fun and to help people
um and but if you ask them that if they
could only pick one it would be to make
money
at that point once they've ticked that
box if they could only pick one it would
be to have fun generally and once
they've taken those two boxes at that
point people then shift to
to the the helping people thing and i
think that's certainly true for me um
like it's it's very nice that right now
the thing that i'm doing does all three
um
but i think yeah when i was starting out
i was like you know what affiliate
marketing selling t-shirts on the
internet i'll do whatever i can to make
money then it was cool i'm making money
now i'll do whatever i can to have fun
while doing this and it's only kind of
now that i've done it for a few years
that i'm now shifting to actually to
realize this point about how having a
wider mission is ultimately the thing
that makes it more satisfying yeah i
think i think purpose is kind of
everything for me and the
the bit you know i suppose i've
have enough time to look back on whether
we're 13 years old or whatever else like
the
it's the same it's ultimately it's the
same as youtube metrics like subscriber
counts are deeply unsatisfying hitting a
million subscribers
isn't
rewarding in any way not not a single
way it's it's
you know it's coming deep down when it
happens and then you're like oh yeah but
it really doesn't feel like anything uh
and it's the same sort of thing for me
in business it's the same sort of thing
like like a big fat balance sheet at the
end of it sure good fine whatever it's
it's an indicator
same as an audience you could do
something with it if you want to but
it's what you're going to do with it
that's more interesting more satisfying
than the accrual of the number hey
friends thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this clip then click here
for the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day